У селищі Покровське, що на півдні Дніпропетровської області, тепер все крутиться навколо води.
Мама каже: "Поїдьте, наберіть мені води".
Ми на транспорті – на мопеді, бо важко ж ходити, носити.
Катастрофа екологічна.
Водопостачання в Покровському немає.
А ту воду, що привозять у цих бочках, небезпечно пити.
У Покровському є трохи питної води, але її не вистачає на всіх.
Місцеві жителі, такі як Ірина Борошнова, повинні самі розв'язувати цю проблему
та організовувати собі воду.
Вона запрошує нас до свого будинку.
Ірина - вчителька математики і фізики,
але, як і більшість селян, її родина живе з того, що вродить земля.
Відсутність води навіть для зрошування стала загрозою для нормального існування місцевих.
Оце рання капуста. Це також пізня - видно по листю, чим вона відрізняється.
Це броколі.
Раніше вони поливали свій посів водою з Каховського водосховища.
Але оскільки дамба була зруйнована, цей варіант поливу для них вже не доступний.
Вони витратили гроші на бурове обладнання, щоб викопати колодязь.
36 метрів завглибшки. Цю воду вони можуть використовувати для зрошування полів...
І для поливу території навколо будинку. Але пити її не варто.
Коли я вранці вмиваюся, чищу зуби, то вона прямо якась така содово-солона.
Таке враження, що я полощу рот содово-сольовим розчином.
Гуманітарна ситуація залишає занепокоєння,
оскільки нестача води все ще впливає на багатьох жителів цієї громади
- не лише поблизу дамби, але й в інших регіонах, які раніше були пов’язані з цим водосховищем.
Отже, справа не лише в кількості, а й у якості води.
Місцева громада страждає і продовжить страждати через цю нестачу.
Селяни тут, у Покровському, відчувають, що їх покинули.
Тоді як у сусідньому Нікополі жителі міста можуть мати воду.
Та в них є інші турботи.
Звідси, де раніше був берег водосховища,
видно окуповану Росією територію
– всього за 10 кілометрів знаходиться Запорізька АЕС.
3 квітня 2022 року вони зайшли туди своїми військами
і, в принципі, вже було зрозуміло,
що вони будуть нас тероризувати з цього місця.
В’ячеслав розповідає нам, що місто може використовувати ту воду,
яка залишилася у водосховищі.
Але росіяни намагаються не дозволяти їм це робити.
Час від часу їм вдається влучити в ціль.
Обстріли залишаються на сьогодні в те місце,
де знаходиться насосна станція.
І виходить, що наразі збільшуються обстріли для того, щоб залишити нас без води.
Місцева влада працює над постійним рішенням.
Прокладають трубу для з’єднання Нікополя з водопроводом міста Запоріжжя.
Зробити це сподіваються до зими.
Після знищення Каховської ГЕС західні команди швидкого реагування вирушили допомагати людям на місцях.
Та цього все одно недостатньо, каже Крістіна Фалконі з Норвезької ради біженців.
Негайна реакція з розподілом води була потужною.
Норвезька рада біженців розподіляє понад 200 тонн води в різних місцях,
і ми продовжуємо підтримувати місцеву громаду так само як і інші організації,
а також національні, міжнародні та місцеві органи влади.
Ситуація потребує тривалішого вирішення.
Місцева влада працює над цим, але, як також згадувалося,
деякі з цих місць також є дуже близько до лінії фронту та щодня знаходяться під обстрілами.
Нікополь, Марганець, Херсон - щодня атакують.
І, звичайно, відновлення та будівництво нових трубопроводів
також є надзвичайно складним завданням.
Цього сезону Ірина та її чоловік Володимир з Покровського садили менше,
ніж зазвичай, знаючи, що води буде мало.
Але вона планує посадити більше городини наступного сезону з надією,
що нова свердловина допоможе зберегти те, що є — принаймні на деякий час.
Не так давно води, що наповнювали цей басейн,
допомагали годувати це село.
Крім того, люди купалися і засмагали на скелях.
Селяни кажуть, що через відсутність води вовки перепливають з іншого берегу.
Ніхто не знає, чи дамбу відновлять,
чи природа заволодіє басейном і тут все заросте бур‘янами.
Може для екосистеми якоїсь, для природи, для тварин це буде добре.
Але це буде погано для нас, для людей, саме для жителів села.
Узимку ситуація стане ще складнішою, вважають експерти.
З приходом зими, а це буде друга зима за час війни,
ми можемо очікувати, що потреби місцевих збільшаться.
Тому що, на жаль, з торішнього досвіду,
водно-енергетична інфраструктура кілька разів ставала мішенню
в різних регіонах країни.
Тому ми боїмося, що цей додатковий ризик може ще більше посилити потреби
та вплив на людей у регіонах, які надзвичайно постраждали від цього браку води.
Ми працюємо як міжнародне співтовариство, як член міжнародної спільноти з місцевими партнерами,
щоб підготувати відповідь для підтримки цих зимових потреб
і гарантувати якомога більше, більше поставок, альтернативних поставок
або зимових рішень для їх зігрівання знову протягом наступних місяців.
Селяни побоюються, що якщо водосховище знову не наповнять,
їм, мабуть, усім доведеться виїхати.